mom-to-be Katy Perry doing the all-star
party helping celebrate the class of
2020
[Music]
hey V where's a Marilyn vibe and showed
off her growing baby bump the singer and
blonde curls in a white gown waltz
barefoot through a sea of silver tinsel
and made it official
you are graduates in three two one
[Music]
Liz OH
kicked it all off with a pumped up
version of pomp and circumstance and
Beyonce told the grads to stay strong
cheering her experience with sexism in
the music industry I know how hard it is
to step out and bet on yourself
there was a pivotal turning point in my
life when I chose to build my own
company many years ago I had to trust
that I was ready but that was terrifying
not enough black women had a seat at the
table so I had to go and chop down that
wood and build my own table
JLo's lesson learned from the tough
times got fired
get your heart broken learning
experience graduate during a global
crisis okay
that's more than a learning experience
that's a growing
Hitler swept up the 20:20 grabs she
could relate to them revealing she never
got a real graduation either when I was
younger I used to fantasize about high
school graduation and you know being
with all of your friends and cap and
gown and the whole thing and then when I
got to that point in my life her
graduation was coming up I found myself
on radio tour with my mom in rental cars
sitting on the floors of airports and I
ended up getting mailed my diploma
Mariah Carey sang hero and Jimmy Kimmel
wore a graduation cap they out of a
pizza box your mother and I are very
proud of you Alicia Keith Martha Stewart
Justin Timberlake so 2020 decided to
test you in more than 70 artists and
celebrities lent their voices to YouTube
originals dear class of 2020 Lady Gaga
said she rewrote and re-recorded her
speech after the massive demonstrations
around the world
you're watching society change in a
deeply important way this change will be
slow and we will have to be patient
but change will happen and it will be
for the better
[Music]